[Music]
all right it is the time a lot of you've
been waiting for you play along with us
we enjoy that
time for our jeopardy warm up we get to
see which of our contestants
knows the most about las vegas so our
contestants tonight
familiar faces it's gentlemen's night
brian loftus
ted florindo and chris matthews who
readily admits he's on a losing streak
the past couple three days come on chris
i have almost
a clue losing yes i know the feeling
it could change tonight we've got our
clue and again whoever wins gets
bragging rights but we've all been
pretty humble because we haven't got a
lot of questions right
chris let's get started remember you've
got 15 seconds so
here is tonight's clue for jeopardy warm
warm-up this
residential street's name is a clever
nod
to one of frank sinatra's most
well-known
songs this is a residential street
in las vegas
15 seconds to think about
[Music]
ted's just guessing you can tell by my
face
she knows me too long one way and then i
went the other chime is up
this really could go a lot of different
ways right yeah frank sinatra's
song all right so let's begin screen
left to right brian loftus how'd you do
with this one
i started with new york and then i
switched it he has a song
stardust and i swear i don't know if i'm
right or wrong
nope that was a good guess that was a
good pretty good guess
i like your train of thought i did i won
new york
oh you know what no
[Applause]
good question tonight right did you get
it right at home but those were good
guesses guys
my way the losing streak continues
thanks for joining us tonight at 6 30.
we'll see you back at 11 o'clock